today's topic i got something for you
broke my three love
my little wifey
my new camaro
in my garage
[Music]
uh what's the age apart
it's not even that this is my husband
he's also my ex's dad
this is what the headlight says
everyone hates me but it's the best sex
i ever had
[Laughter]
okay now i need i need i need a timeline
i need a timeline
i mean the whole thing's weird so
apparently this is the only person she's
ever slept with
not the husband
the current husband
you didn't sleep with the other one so
this is how the article reads dean which
is the woman first met her future sugar
daddy as a sixth grader while visiting
paul's son who was her boyfriend at the
time which was a sixth grader yeah
there's a 24-year nagger
hey hey this story
what the [ __ ] did you say to me hey man
what the what the f what the waiter wait
whoa wait
whoa
hey
yo
she met the dad when she was a sixth
grader yeah yeah so there's like you
know there's like shows like are you
smarter than a fifth grader yeah this
one's are you more vulnerable than a
sixth grader
because 24 year difference she was 13
this man was holding his 30s okay all
right so dean first met her future sugar
daddy as a sixth grader while visiting
paul's son who was her boyfriend at the
time and while the two pre-teen
lovebirds eventually called it quits
they remained friends throughout the
middle school
with dean frequently hanging out with
her
former flame
after school and on weekends right
however a rift opened up after paul's
son got a girlfriend in his teens
whereupon dean increasingly started
talking to his father to avoid being the
third wheel
okay this is where he gets weird from
there that that wait what that's where
it gets weird
it's already weird it's been weird but
it takes another level from there a
whirlwind romance soon blossomed the two
lovebirds started dating when she was
16.
which is legal in ohio so for those who
are like oh my god throw him in jail you
can't
i did have one friend that wasn't okay
with mine and paul's relationship that
friend would never want to come hang out
or even talk to me much at all if he was
around
i mean
i get it yeah
it can make people uncomfortable i can
get that i mean a 24-year age gap it's
like it's like hanging out with your
dad's friend
literally so
there's a couple things in here i mean
there's a lot to unpack i think they're
common about it being the best sex
you've ever had i'm like [ __ ]
you've never had a person
i'm having the best time of my life
you're three [ __ ] you're three
okay this ain't [ __ ] you're three calm
down
calm down
you don't know you don't know about wine
you don't know about beer you don't know
about alcohol that's the best thing of
my life it's just a popsicle calm down
you haven't lived
you're this close to being aborted in
some places
too far in america not in america but
everywhere else
i'll say this
damn you know jokes aside in regards to
him being the best sex yeah is it
playback it's kind of a weird is it the
best sex i've ever had compared to what
uh the best sex i ever had
that's a weird comparison a one to one
is that get rid of what my fingers uh is
it payment do you think it's pretty bad
what you pay back oh yeah i think you
can't hang out i think he was attracted
[ __ ] your dad i mean he was hanging out
with her like i don't know that's why i
don't get if you in your late 30s
hanging out with 13 and 14 year olds if
they're not your kid must be disgusting
it's weird
if i'm not babysitting i'm not even
talking about how the people perceive it
like me being there yeah i just hear
teenagers when i'm on the bus and i just
i'm like please i hope you guys get off
this bus and get run over
right
imagine
hanging out in your home with them
i could you with my relatives of people
and babysitting yes again we'll be
hanging out all the time after school
what the [ __ ] is this will you miss
frizzle mine is the magic school bus
that's creepy
that that's weird to me like what what
24 years like listen i'm not mad at age
gap she was 16 when y'all started that
anything you'd like to say
it's not because it's legal that it
feels right
it's like driving the speed limit i was
like yeah
yeah but technically deadly but get the
[ __ ] out
yes
exactly yes it's like driving this yes
but please remove yourself
if you're doing the speed limit get the
[ __ ] out of my way shout out to ludacris
uh that's crazy
i mean
yeah
that's
not a weird father-son relationship
afterwards too finding out your dad's
piping your ex you think it's a
relationship i don't think it's a
relationship i mean i think dead i don't
know how you're saying stuff like it's
the best sex that's her being petty
that's her being petty especially if you
if they never had sex but but even then
to say that it's the i feel like that's
a gem if they had to be a worst champ
that's like man this is so good
man his young youthful son couldn't give
me what this old geezer could oh that's
payback that's what i said is that
payback that's what i asked i could see
that that's weird
i'm not gonna say that 100 but no what
we have is pure and
[Music]
it's weird
i just want to share my discomfort with
you all now that you guys got the
experience let us know what you guys
think in the comments below anything
else i don't care about the fact that
it's the the the husband of the ex i
don't care about that
it's the age gap that i have a problem
with when wendy started that's what i
have a problem with i would agree
but i i still no no no no no what kind
of dad dates his [ __ ] kid sex that's
weird [ __ ] i would
you talking about yeah you better stay
in lane i'll [ __ ] you little [ __ ] nah
don't even jump like that
[Laughter]
me and everybody find turner ahead like
excuse me
yeah i know i just wanted that
that's crazy not got their attention
that's crazy now i got their attention
you know what i would argue i think it's
more normal that that old geezer is
dating a young woman than it is for
somebody to date their son's ex oh
that's for their daughter's boyfriend
that's weird yeah
what if okay what if people listen them
hanging out was already strange big game
them dating getting married yeah
people imagine
imagine you have a father
all right they got dog and everything
and stuff and they like they got the
father has a whole kids and everything
and he has a relationship with a woman
and then the relationship breaks and
then 30 years after that
the lady goes out with the the brother
of the that's fine right because he the
same age
all this talk about family trees bro i'm
not into incest so i don't
you [ __ ] the brother that's fine hey man
listen
how do you think about that don't that's
just that i just want your attention i'm
just really just what even the son said
to her it's like you did my my father
i'm dating your zaddy oh no he's your
father he's my daddy
is right there
he's like hey ex-boyfriend uh
i mean you want to talk to your brother
i'm your mother-in-law now yeah
in a week let's have a little bit of
respect
imagine your ex is telling you you're
about to birth your brother
i can see how [ __ ] up that is you
wanna know i can see how some people
don't know why we never [ __ ] because i
wanna [ __ ] your dad wow wow that's a jab
i listen you hey listen
the little homie cannot come to any road
session no no no no no listen you walk
through the door and there's ammunition
sitting there if your dad goes out with
your ex
you can't be a rapper
you can
you can be a rapper
you can be a roaster you can be a
comedian you can't you can't be a
comedian because that's you can't make
jokes you can make jokes you can't make
jokes oh you can make jokes but people
are gonna that's good like
like you can't have a self-esteem
you can no you can't but you could be
like hey you know what no you can't i'm
gonna laugh about there's a whole bit
this whole hour special i'm laughing at
my own ass i'm laughing at me i mean you
can laugh at you all you want there's a
limited oh yeah definitely
so you if your dad goes out with your ex
your last name becomes a verb
you know what i mean yeah what's the
dad's last name
yeah let's say his name is branson you
got branson
right
you got petersoned